bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous ce
soir sur rtl france à ce stade
visiblement les pays acp concernés n'ont
reçu ce soir encore aucune notification
officielle concernant leurs ambassadeurs
est ce que le président radouane peut
mettre à exécution sa menace est ce
qu'il y a un intérêt spécifique
je pense qu'il ya avant tout ils ont un
intérêt politique intérieure est lié
premièrement aux élections à venir
n'oublions pas que dans 18 mois et sur
le plan politique ce sera tellement
court il y à de nouvelles élections
présidentielles en turquie donc le
positionnement et la communication et
l'art de la communication
ader de gan est toujours être victime de
ses ennemis n'est ce pas donc ennemis à
l'intérieur et puis et demi à
l'extérieur que peuvent être la
communauté européenne donc voilà il se
victimise et il se présente à son
électorat c'est d'ailleurs face à des
électeurs potentiels à ses partisans un
homme qui l'a lancé cet oukase des spas
qui reste d'ailleurs à se matérialiser
il faut attendre un petit peu et raison
garder on avait l'impression ces
derniers temps d'en rester là et perdon
qui se faisait un peu plus discret ce
que vous direz que le dossier haussmann
à kavala l'a révélé ce que c'est un
dossier extrêmement délicat et sensible
dans l'opinion comme une kirk
alors il fait effectivement j'ai
moi-même effet une émission ce qui
s'appelle mais où est passé monsieur
erdogan donc à il y avait à un recul de
la présence de racheter épique erdogan
dans un las sur la scène internationale
et mais elle a à nouveau c'est vraiment
dans la scène turque qu'il s'implique
parce que les élections à venir bomba
sont effectivement avec les habitants du
pays donc je crois que sur le plan
international il sera toujours prudent
parce que l'économie turque est vraiment
en difficulté
40 % au moins des exportations de la
turquie vont vers l'est l'europe et la
turquie achète 30% de ces produits du
marché européen donc il y a des liens
économiques et les structures
économiques de la turquie ne laisseront
pas à cette situation allait trop loin
vous direz que près le président arnaud
a été piqué au vif dans ce dossier osman
kavanagh est ce que d'ailleurs les
signataires de cet appel à la libération
de l'opposant étaient dans leur rôle
selon vous
les écoutez le problème qui se pose
c'est que ce monsieur est en prison
depuis quatre ans et sans qu'aucun
jugement et procédure ne soit intervenu
donc un moment effectivement il faut
marquer les dérives d'un régime
autoritaire
qui c'est un signal aussi vis-à-vis de
ces un candidat et opposant potentiel
donc il manie fortement le bâton et donc
c'est un message comme que ce soit
monsieur à kavala ou un autre personne
le message qu'ils passent ils voyaient
un jeu je suis prêt à massacrer entre
guillemets à mes opposants mes ennemis
mes adversaires donc et il y avait
raison d'intervenir comme je viens de
l'expliquer parce que quatre ans sans
intervention de la justice en prison et
bien ce n'est pas tout à fait acceptable
et que le profil de la personne
impliquée monsieur kavala n'est ce pas
est un homme du raid de culture c'est un
éditeur il a plusieurs maisons d'édition
il avait créé une une ong qui s'appelle
culture anatolienne donc c'est un homme
d' équilibre qui ne met pas comme
erdogan et son parti
l'islam et l'islamisme en tête de liste
n'est ce pas donc voilà il est dans
l'équilibré cet équilibre ne provient
pas du tout à la stratégie électorale de
monsieur erdogan pour lui effectivement
il y à une inadéquation au plan
diplomatique pour prévoir dans quelles
pourraient être les conséquences d'une
telle mesure de l'expulsion peut-être
d'une dizaine d'ambassadeurs
je crois qu'il faut voir les choses
étape par étape n'est ce pas parce que
monsieur à de galles est un fin
tacticien un bon stratège et un fin
tacticien
donc voilà il a sorti déjà le revolver
mais c'est une grande différence entre
sortir le revolver et à tiré un coup de
feu n'est ce pas donc pour le moment il
a simplement évoqué des menaces il a dit
qu'il allait qu'il avait demandé la
rédaction des actes de personnes
persona non grata donc voilà il a la
volonté de le faire mais entre demandé
la rédaction des documents et les signer
lui-même voyez vous il y a place à la
diplomatie à des négociations merci
beaucoup pour votre analyse gérard
vespière je rappelle que vous êtes
analyste géopolitique fondateurs du web
magazine le monde décrypté